so this article comes out this morning
or in the last couple days I came across
my eyes this morning from ESPN running
talking about the bizarre stuff NFL
players particularly rookie NFL players
are doing with their big signing bonuses
and you and I both worked with the NFL
players and spoke in two rookie camps
and different things over all the years
we've seen some of them doing really
smart things and we've seen some of them
do extraordinarily stupid things yes
with their money of course the stupid
always makes the news right oh
absolutely and that's the one cuz it's
always so sad i buy just shakes their
head and goes that's just dumb with
zeros on it but um you know were you so
I wasn't surprised when I saw this we're
not at all a matter of fact I was at a
rookie camp back that's this past summer
and I had a room full of Dave of 70
rookies and I look at them and all of
them are saying that they they came from
nothing and they didn't have much
growing up and I said listen to me you
have an opportunity right here don't
don't make up for being broke by going
broke and that's trying to make up for
all the things you didn't have by not
having a plan and people say it all the
time oh we can't believe these athletes
that they're so did that order this and
I think to myself but it's no different
than us as regular people doing crazy
stuff with money mm-hmm if spend more on
you make you smell more your man you're
gonna have a problem and so whether
you're miss spending a hundred thousand
or a thousand miss spending is miss
spending and what you want to do is get
intentional get plugged in and most
people don't buy pet Tigers though what
I saw that day what about the unaware
iam in in the car that was more than I
could ask right there that was a little
much young but I tell you one that you
and I've seen a lot yeah is that
obligation help family members yeah a
tremendous toxic relationship too often
not always but too often with close
family and extended family
oh absolutely and they start you know
you got a guy they act like they got
four hundred million dollars and they
got four hundred thousand dollars people
don't on account and
and go buy stuff that and just
completely out of control so if we've
got any professional athletes listening
which we do always whether you're rookie
or not you've worked with them I've
worked with them what are your key
things you tell them I would tell them
first number one understand where you
are that it is an opportunity it's not
an entitlement then you've got to get on
a plan and buy plan meaning you've got
to get the right people around you don't
hand it off to your guy you and I've
heard that phrase a lot makes my Oh
makes mine I've got her sign up on the
back of your neck I got a guy I got a
guy that means you're getting ready to
be broke that means you're handing off
all power and control to someone and
you're gonna be broke like Dave saying
so get intentional get on a plan
understand how much you're gonna be able
to give away understand how much you're
gonna need to live on and then you got
to learn how to save because Dave you
and I know NFL stands for not for long
yeah well professional athletes doing
the thing is the thing that throws it
off is you that are someone who plays at
that level at the pro level and whether
it's basketball or hockey or you know
golf even you know if you play at that
level you have committed 20 plus years
of your life to your craft yes and
somehow it gets stuck in our emotion
that you're gonna get to do it for 20
more years and you're not I mean the
statistics are staggering though NFL
average careers 3.2 years and 78 percent
leave the league permanently physically
disabled and the divorce rate is
fourfold the national average and the
bankruptcy rate is five times the
national average of people leaving the
league and so it's it's a wasteland is
what it is of financial disasters it
looks like the statistics of winning the
lottery is what it looks like they're
very similar stats yeah and because it's
someone that is ill prepared often times
not always but oftentimes emotionally
with their personal level of wisdom to
handle the burden of this and to have
the square their shoulders and look at
these people in their life that are
parasites and say no putting up good
solid Henry cloud-like
boundaries you know and it's just a
really really sad
thing but yeah I think learning to say
no is huge well and I you know what I
would do the best stories and we see
those stories pop up occasionally too so
and so is driving a 1986 Mazda you know
you see that one it's in the parking lot
next to the Bentley with a aquarium in
the trunk you know and whatever but uh
and this is the guy that's gonna make it
yes I mean and it doesn't matter where
he came from
he understands it's not for long and
this is a very short period of time
you're gonna on average that you're
gonna make a very large amount of money
and it's not going to last you your
whole life know you're up soya and Dave
this is really no different than someone
coming into an inheritance or someone
that gets a large bonus it's it's all
going back to being very intentional and
you've got to understand what it is
you're working toward you know I've said
it my last event that we don't want to
work hard just to work hard we're
working hard to make progress and they
altered in order to make progress you've
got to be working a plan and you've got
to have the right kind of people around
you but wait you and I have seen them
that matter making a mane and a half to
million dollar suspended six oh
absolutely and this you know buying
houses buying cars buying for friends
and family and its left and right they
act like they're Elvis or something yeah
it's just out of control and there's
nothing wrong with giving no but this is
just toxic and stupid it is it's not
giving it's just it's the inability to
say no yes and and it's showing a lack
of character on the part of your family
on the part of yourself to look at this
and go this is for a very short period
time actually the best favor you can do
your family is to maintain this money
not not like being greedy but to cause
it to grow and that you can use it for
the rest of your life not just for six
months yes and you know and I don't
really care what you parked next to the
NFL parking garage or parking lot is no
different than the mall parking lot your
parking next to broke people and some of
them just have more zeros that's all it
is
we know the numbers we work on them
every day for this article Espeon
articles just really dead on hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and say
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that your
friends think you've lost your mind